Research is a glimpse of the future.
Computer algorithms are capable of making
digital creatures walk, paint in the style
of famous artists, create photorealistic images
of virtual objects, simulate the motion of
fluids and a ton of other super exciting works.
However, scientific papers are meant to communicate
ideas between experts. They involve lots of
mathematics and terminology. In Two Minute
Papers, I try to explain these incredible
scientific works in a language that is not
only understandable, but enjoyable, two minutes
at a time.
Papers are for experts, but Two Minute Papers
is for you.
If you're interested, let's celebrate science
together, there are two new science videos
coming every week, give it a shot, you'll
love it!
Thanks for watching and I am looking forward
to greeting you in our growing club of Fellow
Scholars!
Cheers!